so you've had an interaction
and perhaps a bit of a friendship with
stephen hawking
uh does it make you sad that he didn't
win the nobel well
all together i don't assign great
importance to prizes because as you said
you know
jean-paul starter who i admired as a
teenager
because i was interested in philosophy
when i grew up on a farm in israel
uh you know i used to collect eggs every
afternoon and i would drive the tractor
to the hills of our village and
just think about philosophy read
philosophy books and jean paul sata was
one of my favorite
and he was honored with the nobel prize
in literature
he was a philosopher primarily
existentialist
and he said the hell with it you know
why should i give
um special attention to this committee
of people that get their self-importance
from awarding me
the price like what what's uh you know
why
why does that merit my attention yes so
he he gave up on the nobel prize
and you know there are two benefits to
that
one that you don't you're not
working your entire life in the
direction that would satisfy the will of
other people
you know you work independently you
you're not after these honors
just for the same reason that you're if
you're not
living your life for making a profit or
money
you can live a more fulfilling life
because you're not being swayed by the
wind you know of
how to make money and so forth uh the
second
aspect of it is you know that um
very often um you know these prizes
um they um
they distort the way we do science
because instead of
um people willing to take risks
and instead of having announcements
only after a group of people converges
with a definite result
you know uh the natural
progression of science is based on trial
and error you know
so reporting some results and perhaps
they're wrong but then other people find
perhaps better evidence and then you
figure out what's going on
and that's the natural way that science
is you know it's a learning experience
so if you give the public an image by
which
scientists are always right you know and
and you know some of my colleagues say
we must do that
because otherwise the public will never
believe us that global warming is really
taking place
right but that's not true because the
public would really believe you
if you show the evidence yes so the
point is you should be sincere when the
evidence
is not absolutely clear or where there
are disputes about the interpretation of
the evidence we should sure say
you know the king is naked okay
there is no point in pretending that the
king is dressed
saying that scientists are always right
scientists are wrong
frequently and the only way to make
progress
is by evidence giving us the support
that we need to make
airtight arguments so when you say
global warming is taking place
if the evidence is fully supportive if
there are no
holes in the argument then people will
be convinced because
you're not trying to fool them when the
evidence was not complete you also show
them that the evidence is not complete
and when there's holes you show that
there's holes and here's the methodology
we're using to try to close those holes
exactly let's sincerely pretend so if
there were no
in a world where there would there were
no prizes no honors
we would act like kids as i said before
we would really be
focusing on the ball and not on the
audience yeah the prizes
get in the way and it's it's so powerful
you